an exponential entrepreneur is an
entrepreneur who is leaning on
exponentially accelerating technology so
Network sensors AI robotics synthetic
biology 3d printing these technologies
that are all on exponential growth
curves they're also relying on what we
call exponential psychological tools
right these are ways to think at scale
flow States things along those lines
things that let Automator scale up their
mental game like never before and
finally they're also using exponential
crowd power tools these are
crowdsourcing crowdfunding incentive
prizes and community building right that
let entrepreneurs get access to capital
get access to expertise really scale up
their reach farther than ever before
right so an exponential in video is
people who are using these three kind of
categories to level up if you want to be
an exponential on venire and you want to
play with exponential technology you
need to understand the kind of growth
cycle that exponential technologies go
on and we use something called the six
DS to talk about this right the first D
is digitalization right a technology
becomes exponential once it becomes
digitalized it becomes represented in
ones and zeros right once that happens
or life becomes an information-based
technology and it hops on an exponential
growth curve right the classic example
being Moore's law as covering
transitions but now we're seeing in all
of these technologies you're seeing in
synthetic biology once we realize that
DNA was essentially can be represented
as a binary code right it hopped on this
exponential growth curve and now
synthetic biology is accelerating five
times the speed of Moore's law that's
the first D and when that happens
there's usually a lot of excitement a
lot of hype a lot of excitement which is
unfortunate because the second D is
deception what happens is these
technologies get introduced and it takes
a while for them to get up to speed
riding like there's all this hype in the
beginning and they fall into this
deceptive period and people kind of
dismiss them 3d printing was in that
deceptive period for a very very long
time robotics AI all these things but
all of the technologies that were
talking
about involved are now moving out of
that deceptive period right
what gardener and the gardener hype
cycle calls the trough of
disillusionment which I think it's a
great term right they're all leaving
that trough of disillusionment what
happens next is they become very very
very disruptive right a classic example
is uber is totally disrupting the
taxicab industry Instagram totally
disrupting Kodak these are these are
classic examples of the disruption after
they move out of this disruptive phase
you look at D monetization this means
that the technology the cost of the
technology itself is propping and
dropping and dropping the money comes
out of the equation so for example once
you could store digital images on a
camera right film was totally
demonetized right it suddenly nobody was
buying roll film anymore pixels
did the same job so the money comes out
of the equation right dematerialization
is what follows so think about all the
1980s or 90s technology that now come
free with your cell phone right we did
Peter and I did a calculation in an
abundance and we were looking at this
and we found in the average cell phone
how is this over like a million dollars
worth of technology from the nineteen
eighty of your GPS locator your
encyclopedia your great radio and record
play your camera video recorder on and
on and on right you can now with
Instagram get access to editing software
that ten years ago was a two million
dollar package and today it's free with
an Instagram account so the d
monetization dematerialization the
technology itself is disappearing
nobody's going out and buying cameras
anymore because it comes on your
smartphone the next thing that happens
is democratization and this is what
happens when these technologies
themselves become cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper cell phones the classic
example back in the 80s these were a
luxury technology right that only the
wealthiest could have and then it's kind
of slowly moved down the scale until
where we are today where 50% of the
world doesn't even just have a cell
phone they have a smartphone right the
or super computer in their pocket that's
how much you know that's how much these
things have been democratized access
becomes available to anyone